and sports secretary at Grant Shapps
joining us at from just down the road on
Abington green at minister very good
morning to you and you'll have heard
that breaking news in just the past
couple of minutes the statement from
easyJet that they could no be grounding
the majority of their fleet yeah that's
right I seen that statement look I'm
meeting with the whole of the transport
sector this week but mainly to feed into
an economic and business committee
chaired by the Chancellor in order that
we can do what we've said all along
which is we understand this is a crisis
like we haven't seen before where
businesses which are otherwise
sustainable otherwise good businesses of
course should be able to survive through
this this situation and that's what
we're going to be trying to put into
place for all businesses and individuals
in this country as we join this great
national effort to defeat this virus we
know that even before the statement from
easyJet that they are going to be
canceling a number of flights that the
war noisy it's coming from the aviation
industry that that may they might be
requiring a bailout of sorts are you
minded to provide it well we know that
aviation of course is at the forefront
in many ways because the first thing
that stopped is travel internationally
in particular but actually we want to
you know make sure that as I said you
know companies and and individuals
organizations who are in a good state
not those that we're going to fail
anyway but the good state are able to
continue and and so we're be looking at
all of these measures I'll be discussing
them with the Chancellor and the prime
minister later today in those
discussions with the sector are ongoing
including summits I've got in transport
with railroad Aviation Hall years later
today and later this week it sounds very
much like bailing out the airlines is an
option that remains on the table for now
at least well there are lots of
different options here including some
other things that people have been
looking for for example HMRC offer a
time
pay there's obviously issues over the
way that various different taxes
regulations fall last week we before I
was very active in ensuring that
Airlines weren't having to pointlessly
fly what I was calling ghost planes
empty half-empty fully empty because
there was a slot allocation rule at
airports and I lobbied the European
Commission to change that and indeed
they have changed it so there's lots of
different ways to assist but this is now
a great national effort that every
organization every individual every
citizen in this country and indeed
around the world is having to join in
order to make sure that we can and will
in the end defeat this virus I wonder if
we might speak more generally about the
government's response to Corvette 19 and
many people will welcome the
announcement that there are going to be
daily televised briefings from the
government we will talk in and more
detail about the government's
communication strategy in just a second
but many people watching this will be of
one mind with one big question in their
head what is it that the government
knows that the CM or the CS or the Prime
Minister knows that means that I will
approach to tackling corvid 19 is
markedly different from pretty much the
rest of the world
well I think that if you are looking for
this sort of a uniqueness of the British
approach it would simply be those
initials you mentioned the chief medical
officer the chief scientific officer it
is a real desire to be driven by the
evidence and by the science now I don't
think that necessarily means that our
approach is markedly different as you
say but I do think it means that we
deploy each of these different measures
at the appropriate time and there'll be
another Cobra planning session later
today the Prime Minister will chair that
I'll be at will we'll be discussing all
the things that were in that overall
action plan issued near the start of
this crisis so we are just being
entirely science led we're not doing the
things that you know sometimes perhaps
are are happening elsewhere just because
it seems like a popular thing to do we
want to know that the scientists back in
and that's I suppose the hallmark of
of this country's response but the
accusation that is being made is that
the government is reacting in some cases
in some ways more slowly than European
partners the United States you'll have
heard the news about Los Angeles and and
New York simply because the Health
Service cannot cope as it stands figures
from the NHS released in January show
that in terms of critical care we're
needing capacity even before covered 19
all over 4,000 adult critical care beds
three and a half thousand of them are
occupied 312 pediatric intensive care
beds 247 of them occupied and all that
before we expand the system try to hire
new intensive care nurses I mean how
confident are you that there is the
capacity to to treat people what I think
surprise any of any of your viewers that
of course something like this at the
scale of this virus is an enormous
capacity challenge for any health system
throughout the world it doesn't matter
where you are but just because of the
size and scale of it and of course it is
also the case that it makes a lot of
sense to ensure that we do things to try
to manage the pressures on the on the
health service but the actual
decision-making as you've seen and
you've seen the Prime Minister you'll
see it again today flanked by those
medical and scientific experts every
single decision that we've made has been
based around what does the science say
what's the medical evidence and we're
going to be actually publishing all the
background evidence and of course it's
quite right that some people will have
different opinions and really we want to
hear those opinions because it's very
very important that we get this right
but we are making every single possible
effort to do that and doing in a
completely transparent way I would say
the UK is probably just been at a
slightly different stage obviously the
comparable places like Italy but also a
little behind where France and Germany
are it's not that we're not going to get
there but of course our responses are
timed in a different way unique to the
particular stage of this that we're in
in the UK but but at this stage in the
spread of corvid 19 we have the health
secretary issuing a call for help from
industry to expand
of ventilators available to the NHS we
spoke over the weekend to one person who
didn't think that was necessarily
practicable let's just have a listen the
biggest providers are in America guess
where they're going to supply the next
biggest of strangely enough is New
Zealand and they're looking after the
Southeast Asia the rest of Europe and of
course guess where the European
manufacturers are going to sell their
stuff to because you know it's to Europe
and we're not in Europe anymore what
information have you had that suggests
that we will be able to mass-produce
ventilators in the coming weeks first of
all we've been buying ventilators over
the last few weeks and months so that's
been an ongoing process secondly we are
in Europe still that we don't physically
geographically move and if you were
listening to some other radio broadcast
this morning you had no chief execs very
large manufacturing advanced
manufacturing organizations who very
much up for the manufacturing of
ventilators in fact I've had two
approaches from constituents companies
advanced manufacturers this weekend and
today there'll be a phone number coming
live today and an email address for
people who want to offer manufacturing
assistance that would be a base as a
business department number that will
come available I think this is all part
of sort of this great national effort to
work together and do everything we
possibly had as a nation to solve this
problem and make sure that we protect
the elderly and the vulnerable in our
society who are the people who are most
likely going to be the ones who would
need the ventilators themselves and I
wonder if we can talk about the way in
which the government has been
communicating its strategy to the wider
public there has been some confusion we
had the chief scientific officer at
talking about Harrod immunity then the
health secretary saying it wasn't part
of the strategy you had the the prime
minister in his press briefing at saying
that we didn't need to ban mass
gatherings then briefing to the press
that that was a strategy going forward
do you think the government has been in
command of communications actually I
mean the action plan published right at
the beginning actually outlines
virtually all these things so you know
things like home isolation and you know
households staying at home even elderly
and vulnerable people I'm staying at
home all of those things are already
outlined in the action plan the question
really I guess this is what you're
coming to is really that of timing and
when each of these different elements
come in and again we will be driven by
the scientific advice on this which I
think's absolutely the right approach
you can never over communicate I
entirely agree with that but I do think
that it's important that we do not get
knocked off the course
of what this country is because I'm very
well so far which is to follow the
medical and scientific advice rather
than doing things which just sound good
but perhaps don't have the right impact
at the right moment in time why then did
the government announced that millions
of people over the age of 70 may have to
be isolated for as much as four months
why did they announce that through an
anonymous briefing to a political editor
a political journalist and not the Prime
Minister standing at a lectern or
yourself or the health secretary
speaking to the public directly why is
public health policy being given to the
public
via anonymous briefing that's just not
true if you look at the action plan
which was published at the beginning of
this it's literally written in there so
it's just not true
about that accusation but also I mean I
would say it's useful before we're
actually asking over 70s to isolate my
parents for example in their their 80s
my father 88 I was speaking to them this
weekend and helping them to set up an
online shopping account so they can get
their groceries delivered and it's
practical and helpful for people to know
what's coming down the line which is why
it is written in the action plan itself
in order that they can get themselves
prepared and my mother for example
hasn't had the opportunity to read the
action plan my mother discovered that
she may very well have to spend four
months in her own home away from her
family through an anonymous briefing to
a political journalist now we heard from
the the health secretary at the weekend
at the following let's just have quick
listen to this
but just be crystal-clear on the elderly
the government will be asking the over
70s to self isolate potentially for a
period of months at some point in the
future that is in the action plan yes
and we'll be setting it out with more
detail when that's the right it's the
right time to do so because we
absolutely appreciate that it is that is
a very big ask of the elderly and the
vulnerable and it's for their own self
protection
made two absolutely clear that he does
not feel that that was the right time to
talk about it the right time to provide
detail on that particular piece of
public policy a large part of the
strategy instead emerged on a blog on a
Facebook post written by a political
journalist and not from elect and so
again I ask do you think that the
government is completely in control of
the way in which it is informing the
public like afraid I can't be in control
of every blog that a political
journalist decides to write but what I
do know is that as the health sector
just said it's actually in the action
plan which was widely covered by the
newspapers at the time including that
point and I think it is useful for you
and me people with elderly parents and
relatives to be able to prepare them and
this is what it is I mean I can't tell
you otherwise this is a big national
effort required for a international
crisis and people will need to prepare
in that way that's why we're moving to
daily press conferences from today as
well but our approach is to be
completely open with it and publish all
the information all the background and
try to give people the best possible
advice as we pull together as a nation
to defeat this thing